I have been such a huge fan.
It's the understatement of the planet.
This is a bucket list moment
for me to be able to talk about all things love,
home, family, being self-taught.
But can I start at like, word, go,
(laughing)
because I found some I had never seen before
and it really blew my mind.
There was a commercial--
Yeah, right.
That you saw.
Don't gimme too much credit here.
It wasn't that I saw it.
Every male in the Central Texas region
saw this commercial you're referring to
and we're drawn to moths, like flame,
to this town, trying to meet the beautiful
and talented Joanna Stevens.
You know what it was, tire technology coming out
of those lips.
And eyes, those beautiful eyes--
(overlapping discussion)
Those eyes and those beautiful voluptuous lips.
And tire technology made for an insatiable--
They made me say, we will not be undersold a few times,
because like we don't believe it.
So I had to be like aggressive,
we will not, but it felt so, even watching him,
and I'm like, Oh my gosh, I'm talking about tires.
Do you need the cattle product
and talking points on a daily basis?
Oh yeah.
Oh, if I don't hit that stuff,
we all live in that world.
You're like flowing, you're going,
and they're like, Talking point,
talking point, selling point, talking about that.
Would you be kind enough to tell us
that you will not be undersold again in this, Joanna.
We need to believe it?
(overlapping discussion)
Yeah, exactly.
We will not be undersold.
(laughing)
I felt that, I felt that, yeah.
Yeah.
We felt it.
I don't know why it made me giggle,
(overlapping discussion)
because it's like seeing you this close also,
I'm just so delighted.
I used to have lines, but about we will,
what did I use to say about the lug nuts?
I don't know, but that's my point.
Men and lug nuts.
Yes.
And sexy women is a very potent combination.
What was date number one?
Like you see her talking lug nuts,
what did you, what was your next move?
What was the first date?
What was the vibe?
Tell me.
I was physically at the tire shop when I first met Chip
and I was walking out as he was walking in the doors,
and I just, kind of my personality.
I just go straight out the door, and he's like,
Wait, wait, wait, you're that girl on the commercial,
and right off the bat, I roll my eyes.
I'm like, Oh, he's one of those guys.
She had heard this a few times, turns out.
I thought this was an original line.
He turns around and starts following me,
and so then I'm taking a break outside, sitting outside.
So we chat for about an hour,
and then he leaves and I think,
oh, that was sweet guy, he was a great customer.
I actually went to his, I looked at the system
and wanted to see how much that Chip Gaines
has come to my dad's tire shop.
So you basically, through your family computer,
did a Google search--
I did a Google search--
And got receipts--
Yes.
And was like, who is this guy--
He paid for all of the statements, his invoices,
so I was like, okay.
Okay, so the first date.
First date, so there's this little house
that was like they did a buffet-style, home-style dinner
on the weekends, and you would go
and it was like this beautiful bed and breakfast,
but they would just serve dinner.
And we just, all I remember is Chip talking.
I don't think I said maybe two things
because he was just talking and talking,
and I was like, gosh ,this guy knows how to talk.
And it wasn't like gab, talk, talk, talk.
It was just everything he was saying
was so interesting to me.
And then--
And then?
Chip is playing this game with his friend that's like,
Hey, let's see how long, I think it was like,
what were you guys doing about--
I picked the wrong girl to play this game with,
I will say that.
So explain the game.
Long story short, you go on a date and then you play
a little game with your friend.
And so I was going to see how long it would take
for her to call me back.
But I ran into a brick wall in that regard.
Months and months go by,
and my friend and I are like, what is--
So me and my friends are like, Oh, he didn't call,
and they're like, Would you call him?
I was like, I'd never call him.
No.
She never called.
So then I don't call him,
and then three months later, he calls me and he was like,
Okay, I'm done playing these games.
I'm sitting here going, what games.
I'm done playing these games,
literally came outta my mouth.
Like that's it.
Three months later.
Let's quit jacking around.
And she was like, Nobody's been jacking around.
What's wrong with you?
And I was like, I've been waiting on you to call.
She was like, I'm not at calling you.
So you, what, calls?
We go on a date that night,
we go to a basketball game,
and then ever since, it was, we were engaged
a year later.
Well, thank God you started stopped--
Playing chicken.
Yes.
Jo, if you'd just picked up the phone--
Wouldn't do it.
This whole thing would've been
a lot more efficient.
That's probably why I never had any boyfriends
because I would never call any.
I mean, I was so traditional.
Now it all makes sense.
I am too.
Yes.
I want to be a woman who--
I want you to pursue me.
I don't wanna--
And yet, in business I am--
She's a boss.
Very different.
Yeah, that's true.
I'm a woman in the boardroom and much more tentative
in the bedroom, as a twist on the Mick Jagger quote.
Yes.
Sure.
I am, you know--
It's funny, Jo is exactly opposite.
I knew this was coming exactly.
Exactly opposite.
It's evolution.
We want the man to walk into that cave and say,
Hey, you're mine.
She's got this swing set up in our bedroom and--
(overlapping discussion)
(speaking faintly)
I would love a swing, but there's no swing.
Love swings by Magnolia.
They would sell like hotcakes.
Love swings, that's good.
You can put it on the front porch or the bedroom.
I mean after 18 years of marriage, I think,
this is the 2.0, we've all been looking for.
Yes, the spice we were needing.
(upbeat music)